the jurgen experience welcome to
episode 1666.
[Laughter]
[Music]
there can be only one why
i don't know that's the rules thumbs the
rules that's a terrible rule
that's like the worst rule but for
episode 1666
there was only one option that was you
oh thank you i'm honored by that thank
you so much joe
it's so nice to be here dude so nice to
see you
it's you're such a good friend that
every time i see you i'm transported
like there's no time lost yeah you know
what i'm saying when you're
so tight with someone that when you see
them again
you're like transported yeah like you're
immediately
back to where i last saw you again
there's no like hey
god i haven't seen you in a while how
are you
what's going on it's like yeah
that's real friendship i mean that's it
if it's not that what is it
i'm super concerned about this with
catching fire we're surrounded by
candles and uh i believe this wig is
flammable
yeah that wig is from china i don't know
what it is that could be some bizarre
synthetic that could be anything
this is the hair of a billionaire who
said the wrong [ __ ] no
[ __ ] and they just they probably made
him grow his hair first
he probably kept him in a tunnel
somewhere and made him eat rats whatever
rats he could catch
yeah and just give him hair vitamins
and then when his hair was long enough
to make a wig out of it they let him go
that's a lot of work to get some hair
yeah now all he does is coach
john cena he his job is to coach john
cena on what to say dude that was weird
that was really weird that was one of
the weirdest things i'm not a fan of
or not a fan of john cena no john cena
opinion right
but that was just an odd it was scary
because they want
it's a lot i guess it's just a lot of
money man the chinese dollars
here's how much money it is ready for
this that movie made 160 million dollars
the opening weekend
i believe 134 million of it was from
china
oh god oh god we gotta get in
let's do our apologies in china i need
to learn mandarin and start talking [ __ ]
just say hi
start doing my act in mandarin it sounds
cool
it sounds great well amazing the most
impressive thing about that video
was not just that china got john cena to
cuck but also
that john cena speaks perfect mandarin
yeah how long does that take it's a
mystery i don't know man it was just
strange that's like
that's some really really the most it's
again like you know we're watching that
fight
oh my god reflexes when we're watching
that fight last night
and you're just watching it and you're
trying to make sense of the new
reality you know because it's like you
got to accept it
but he's wearing a pikachu medallion
fighting like the best boxer alive today
you know and but you have you have to
watch it
from the perspective of like well this
is what is happening now
because otherwise you get this weird
spinning vertigo
like what the [ __ ] universe am i in same
thing when you're like watching john
cena do some
weird apology and mandarin
it's this sense of like what right this
is a
malfunction this is a breakdown right i
don't get this when in the history of
the united states
like imagine like some old video of like
john wayne
doing some apology in another language
it's just weird it is weird but it's a
warning
to to everybody right the people that
don't they're not taking this
sort of cultural shift seriously when
you see
an enormous alpha male in john cena john
cena's arms are so big
it looks like they're supposed to be a
foot longer but someone sawed them off
and put like a a fist here it's like if
my
forearm like went down only to here and
then the fist was there
his wrists are enormous he's like he's
such a gorilla
right and to see that guy saying it in
chinese and you read what he actually
said it's like
it's hard to say right because one thing
i tried to give him the benefit of doubt
i was like what did he actually say
because i don't speak mandarin
right right i wish somebody maybe that
that spoke manager could translate it
and and tell me whether or not that was
accurate right i'm assuming it was
accurate because i haven't heard
anything
you know people speak mandarin must have
gotten a hold of it since then sure
but it was just weird to see an apology
for just saying that a country exists
that's essentially what it was right he
said taiwan
is a country and he said that i mean
that's all he said wrong like
taiwan was going to be the first country
to see the movie
yeah that's right you can't say that
which is [ __ ] you know also that
thing that just popped up they said it
was a mistake
but being apparently made it so that
if you image searched the tiananmen
square guy holding the suitcase
didn't show up on the day of on the
anniversary of the tiananmen square
massacre and so
everybody's like what the [ __ ] just like
are you
are you like owned by china now
you know that's that's a that is a
really strange
form of invasion isn't it it's like it's
not at the normal kind of invasion where
we're thinking about invasions from old
historical versions of invasions but
that's not how it works anymore
now it's you know if you get your
technology into another country
if you become the supplier of a lot of
their pharmaceuticals if you
all these things then you don't really
need to invade
you know what i mean if you've bought up
a lot of their property
you don't need to fly with jets you
don't need because you're buying it
you're like no
that's like to me that's the that's
where countries like the united states
what makes them so amazing is also this
huge
terrible weakness which is they have a
permeable membrane
[ __ ] can get in there easier than other
places you know and like especially now
with the ability to like just have a
thousand ai bots running
various twitter accounts expressing kind
of similar
sentiment regarding whatever the [ __ ] it
is you want to promote yeah
that's crazy you could just warp
people's minds any way you want
i mean you know we i have we have no i'm
not just talking state
agencies either i mean just cobbles of
like
anarchists who feel like just [ __ ]
around with the zeitgeist could
theoretically just put out a [ __ ] ton of
bots or phone banks of people putting
weird ideas into the
culture that you know you hear it enough
times you start thinking i guess that is
true
right that must be true i don't know if
you've ever had the thing happen
where you're just scanning twitter and
you see some completely
wrong like deeply wrong
fact in physics but you didn't you were
just [ __ ] or something so you're
like well that's interesting
then later you repeat it without looking
it up to see if it's true and then you
go back
to see it this happened i mean you
realize like three tweets above that
tweet
it's like the guy's like i'm the
reincarnation of marilyn monroe
you know what i mean like oh [ __ ] i
repeated
yeah some fact i heard from a guy who
thinks he's the reincarnation of marilyn
monroe
literally at dinner yeah you know that's
what i'm saying is
it leaks out and so it's just trippy you
know it's just weird
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience